in this course from oliver archer you
will improve your django and tailwind
css skills by creating a netflix clone
you will learn how to recreate the
design of netflix and implement some
simple functionality hello wonderful
people it's autry dev i decided that oh
why shouldn't i create a jungle clone of
netflix
so i know that if you don't know what
netflix is
so this is netflix the original website
it is unlimited movies unlimited tv
shows and more
so it allows you to watch
movies and tv shows okay
online so this is the original website
of netflix
and this is my version of netflix let me
switch today so you can see from here
that
i am running on localhost
localhost 48000 sorry
okay so this is it this is my version of
netflix
you see
this is it it almost looks the same
i really did a good work with it
i did well so it has the sign in the
authentication system
authentication system begged in
okay
my pc is a little bit slow so you guys
should pardon me that so i'm going to
log in
okay
then
provide my password
then let me log in
okay so you see when you login into if
you have used netflix before you'll be
asked to choose a profile and
because i have already tested it that's
how there's so many profiles so you can
add a new profile by going to this
clicking on this button it's going to
send you to a page where you can create
a new profile which is this place but i
don't want to create a new profile so i
just go back
and choose the end of the profile so the
profile you have two types of profile
one now you can watch all videos and one
profile for only kids
okay so i just choose this
okay so you see this is the home page
all right
you can see
so i just have two movies because i
can't compete with nice flicks
so
i let me click on a movie
and it's going to take me to
the detail page of the movie so i
clicked on viking so this is the detail
page of i can see giving me some
description about the movie
now just some
some placeholder tests and if i want to
watch the movie this is the button here
i click here
it sends me to
the page where
the movie is going to be shown just like
how netflix does it
and this is it
let me play
okay
it's
as you can see where it's playing but
the image that i use is just i just use
some placeholder image uh video so it's
it shows nothing but the one that you'll
be
demoing here you would use some shorts
fake videos so you can see this thing
just popped out okay so this is
basically what you are going to build
you can expand upon its ads
payment system the only thing i didn't
add was the payment system and
the magic behind netflix that i can't do
anything about
so
this is basically what we are going to
do we are going to build our own version
of
netflix using jungle
the most the best framework ever
so
guys let's jump into it and let's blow
this thing up
okay guys so
let's jump into the video and let's
create our own version of netflix so
before we jump into the video i
because i'm a wonderful person and i
want this thing to be as simple and as
understandable as it can be
i went ahead and was created my a
starter file so that we just cut off
some
unnecessary parts something that you
already know about sorry so
this is the repo i'm going to leave
there the link to the repo in the
description below so that you can have
access to this repo so when you come to
the repo there there are two branches
the main branch is going to contain the
completed projects and when you switch
or when you switch
the branches
and
when you switch the select over here you
can choose
the starter file here the starter branch
here sorry
when you choose it it's the starter
branch contains everything about
the
contains that the starter first needed
for this project okay
so
just switch there then go to code
then you can clone it or you can
download as a profit and just open it up
inside your favorite
uh text editor or code editor i am going
to use visual studio code as you are
okay
so
let me close this stuff so we're not
going to use it again
all right so this is the repo
for the project
it has two branches the starter branch
and the main branch the main branch is
for the completed projects
and
the starter branch is for the brand that
contains all the starter
files okay
so we can you come here you clone it i
have some templates i've provided some
templates and some static files
which are the images that we are going
to use okay so when you clone it
you are going to see
this something like this sorry
something like this
you have
a
normal jungle project that has been
generated with django dash admin starts
project and i gave it a name
django netflix okay so inside the
starter files to add a static file
folder you see some
images and some styles of css over here
which was generated with tailwind
css so i have patched a table in css
file
so this is it
and inside there
uh what's the name the template you have
some a couple of templates
that has been created for you already
and now you said i used
i used a tow in css as usual my favorite
css framework okay
so
this is it so this is
let me let me talk about the changes
that i've made in the files that were
generated by the django dash item so i
change this to
files
the settings.py file and the url.ui file
over here so inside the settings the uh
py file
i change i added
this inside the desk of the template or
the directories of the template i added
the directory for
this template folder over here
and
when you scroll down
you see i've done some magic over i said
i'll be able to use our static files or
be able to hold our static files
so i added the static roots
the media route
the
media url and the static files
there's okay
so because you are going to use a
development server
we are
we have to find a way of saving our
media files and
in our static files so
i added the static
out of this line of code which allows us
to save our static
and media files whilst we are still in
development okay all right so these are
just
the changes that i've made in
the files that were generated by the
jungle dash admin all right
so let's continue let's get into the
action of the
the the the project okay so the first
thing that i'm going to do is you're
going to create
a new app okay you're going to
create a new app you're going to call it
also python stats
no sorry
pythonmanage.poi
oh what is wrong with my head again
what is your pui
start
uh up the name you're going to call it
score
i'm sure i'm going to get an error
somewhere
okay
no arrow clay let's collect this
okay so we have created our our new app
over here so let's close it
let's
move up and inside our installed
apps let's add it to it
let's add core
all right
nice one and
the next thing i want to do is you want
to add a url.py file here so that will
be able to
uh
somewhere of
make our urls modular based on the apps
itself
instead of having all our urls big
directly inside the main url your pi
file okay all right
so
let's add a new file here call it
urls.pui
all right
so inside that you have the pi file you
are going to first import path
okay then the next thing you are going
to do is also have a url of a urls
pattern
list okay
so first import
sorry i thought i'm
writing javascript
so from
jungle
dot
urls
import
path
oh sorry not this part
yes
this way
then
we are going to have an app name because
we are going to use a namespace inside
our main
url
so
app name is going to be course to call
then you have a urs
pathfinder list
like this
all right
this is it we are done with
this for the mean time let's close it
and inside the main url py file
this one here the one that was generated
by jungle that's admin
and the order one that you cloned
you are going to add
you are going to include
the other urls
so
path
and you are going to give it to the root
the root
route okay
so and you are going to give it an
include
and you are going to
pass it
call
dot urls
give it a namespace
you can see you are getting some error
here so you have to import include
namespace
the next phase is going to be across to
call
all right so let's import this include
include can be imported from django dot
urls
all right like this
so you can't save it now you're done
okay so
it's basically you you're done with this
okay you're not done with it so
since you are done with this thing the
next thing i want us to look at is our
models okay
so inside the course
the core
folder open the modup ui file
all right
okay so first we are going to start by
creating our own uh
custom user because we just want to
extend it a little bit by just adding
just
one fill to it okay so we don't want to
change the authentication
system
or
anything
it's not anything special so we are just
going to use the
the abstract user instead of the
abstract base user which allows us to
create a fully fledged
or a fully flexible
uh
custom user but i just going to use the
abstract user okay which just allows us
to just extend the thought of
the user which jungle provides to us
okay so from
django
dot
contrib
dot
dot models
import
substrate
i always put spell this thing wrong
abstract
abstract user
like this okay
so let's go ahead and create our custom
user
class
i always call them custom user i don't
get confused with them and they are
going to
inherit from the abstracts
sorry
what are they trying to explore
abstract user
like this
all right
so the only thing that you're trying to
add is trying to give it a profile
filled
all right
so profiles and it's going to be a mini
not a mining
many
too many fold
sorry sorry sorry guys sorry
it seems my brain is on
some overload so models
dots may need to be difficult
oh what is going on
many too many photos just like this and
this is going to be to
the
profile
profiles
table
okay you are going to have
now equals to
and blank
equals two
like this all right
so this is it this is it
okay so we are done with our user
the next thing i want to do or
look into is
the profile
the profile the profile model okay so
class
profile
and we are going to
inherit from models
dot model
oh sorry
right
all right so
the profile is going to have a name all
right so a profile is supposed to have a
name
the profile is going to be the netflix
profile okay
the one that you usually create
so you can use to watch a movie
if you are familiar with netflix you are
supposed to know that
chat thought
so we are going to use
a character float and it's going to have
a max length
of two to five
okay it's going to be required so
so and
the next thing is going to be an age
limit
so that you know whether it's for kids
or
it's for or so you show them the
appropriate content okay
all right
what's all this what's this
all right sorry guys so that was going
to be a model it's also going to be a
models
not char field
i'm going to have a max length
of 10
and it's going to be
choices
and going to be age and that's called
choice
and that's called choices so let's go
and create that choices still
choices are up here
say a choices
gonna be close to
a topple
or a two pole
then we're going to have to
to fold in it
okay so one is going to be for all
and the other is going to be
so
the first one is the one that is going
to be saved to the database and this is
the one
the one which is going to be displayed
to a user okay
and the next one is going to be kits
and kits all right
so that's what's going to be used here
and the next thing now we want here is a
uuid for this profile
so we are going to use a models
dot
uuid field
all right
we are going to set a default for it
which is going to be of course to uuid
dots
so let's first import the uid a uid
module
from jungle so it from python sorry
import uid
okay
so uid
and there is a version called uid4
okay
this one here i like the four
all right so you are done with the
profile model
so the uid is going to allow us be able
to request for
a particular module or is going to make
it
that uh
how do i put it differentiate between it
okay so class the next thing i'm going
to build is the
movie class or the movie model
so we're going to show you guys for
models that
model
then a movie as usual has a title
so let me claim this one there it's not
a name
so title
then it's going to be a models
the childhood
and the max length
is going to be equals two to five
the next thing we are going to have is a
description of the movie
so
it's going to be
models
dots char filled
oh no sorry
we can't store
the description in the chat we are going
to use a text area
a text folder sorry
what did i just spell text
text dot test
test vote
okay we are going to set it blank
equals to
and
null
equals true
all right here is supposed to be capital
you're not writing javascript
all right
this is the most interesting language
and the best framework ever okay
so created i'm going to add a created
photo that is going to be a models
dot
diff
time thought
we are going to add an auto
now
add equals to
so
this is going to add the
the date
the time and the date and time that the
movie uh
the movie class was created to this fold
okay so we don't need to go and find out
or put in the time ourselves all right
it will be added for us automatically
right so the next thing that we want to
add or the next photo we want to add is
the uuid field
so that is also going to make the movie
going to have helped us differentiate
between the movies okay so
models dot ui default
okay so now we are also going to give
down to a default
which is going to be of course uuid
dot u
id
all right
and the next thing that you want to do
is add
the type of movie whether is it a
seasonal movie or it's just
just a single movie okay
so at first i didn't actually want to
add this part but
it's it makes sense you can't have a
netflix with just only
uh
was single movies you have to have
seasonal movies too okay all right so it
makes sense
starford
no it's our fault
and the max length
it's also going to be third
and you are going to use choices
going to be close to
movie
and that's called choices
all right
so let's create the movie choices over
here
over here
[Music]
then
you are going to have
one seasonal
like this
all right
and
sees now sorry she's now
what about
oliva come on come on
all right
so
the next one is going to be
what's uh what's the name single
thing girl
and yeah it's going to be saying girl
all right
so yeah the movie choices so
see it's supposed to be choices
this way
that way
all
right the next thing i want to add is
what's the name
the video is supposed to have a video
file or a video
so let me let me explain to you
the database setup so you have a movie
a movie a movie thought a movie table
that is going to hold all the movies
that are inside the database
and inside a movie
table
a particular instance you're going to
have videos the video can be just one
video if it is a single
it's a single movie or a single type of
movie but it can hold many instances of
the the movie
uh what
what's the name
many instances of the movie model
okay so if it's a seasonal movie so in a
seasonal movie you have a lot of movies
that are linked to that particular movie
but if it's a single movie it just has
one movie okay i hope it's it's it's
clear right
then so we are going to have videos
which is going to be a models
that many too many
many too many
many to many fold
and it is going to be related to
the video
filled
right
okay
then
the next thing
that is going to be s is going to be
you want a flyer
or a poster for it so i'm going to call
it a flyer so it's going to be a models
dot
image field
and i'm going to choose that it should
be uploaded to
upload to
where where should we upload it to
flyers yes
all right
and
we are going to the every movie is
supposed to have an age limit so that
will be able to
know which kind of movie to show to each
age limit okay
so it's going to be
also going to be equals to a models
dot
chart field
the max length
this is
this is going to be 10
and
their choice is going to be a choices
so choices
which is
the age
choices
all right
okay okay i hope you guys are following
me alright so
this is it you are done with the movie
uh the movie model
so let's jump into the
video model where we are going to hold
our individual
video all right
or movie file all right so now it's also
going to be a model dot
model
so
it's going to have a name it can have a
title so let's say it's an
it's a seasonal movie so the seasonal
movie can have a title that particular
video instance can have a title let's
see episode 1 episode 2 episode three
but in the in the case of a a single
video then
giving it a that single video instance a
title doesn't make sense okay you are
going to make it a models
the childhood
we are going to make its max length
of
two to five
blank equals to
blank equals two so that
those uh
the seasonal movies
uh the single movies can
escape
this field without passing it any
uh value
and not only cost true
all right
then
the next thing that we need is the most
important thing the file
the video file itself so there is going
to be a models
dots
file field
okay so this is it and you are going to
choose an upload
upload to
i'm going to upload it to movies
all right
okay so guys we are done with our
database setup so this is the model that
you're going to use for this project
right so this is it
one here
video
movie profile and a custom user model
okay so save it up save it up
okay
so
this is the models done completed all
righty let's jump into
the views okay so let's start writing
some views and see
the magic that we are putting together
all right
so
in this uh this series or
this series
in this today i am going to use
the class-based approach okay so
let's first import from
jungle.views
import
view
right like this
okay let me click clear away this
this annoying comment
all right
i'm so happy to be recording back again
oh i miss you guys
all right so
the first thing you're going to do is
you're going to create
an index page or let's say the home page
so
let's create a view that is going to
handle that so
i'm going to call it hope as you you are
home
there's no way like home nowhere like
home so it's going to inherit from the
view
all right
so let's go on so
inside our crate hey sorry in our gets
it's going to just handle get so it's
going to take itself
they taking requests
and taking some acts and quarks
right
then when
when i get requested to me to this view
here you want to return
a render
okay i want to return a render
render has to return request
the request
then the template that we are sending
back so inside when you check the
template folder
from the static file i said
that you cloned you are going to see
this
index.html file here that is our
homepage all right
so atmo hey sorry
i'm so excited i'm making a lot of
mistakes index
dot atm all right
so this is our
our simple
home page right
so
let's what what do i want us to do let's
add it to our url ui file okay
so that will be able to preview it
not this url wi-fi let's close that one
up
and let's open
the urls of your file inside the call
the call what's the name
the call folder or the call directory
all right
so
path
i'm going to pass in path
and they are going to give it the roots
directory
and you are going to use the home
dot as view
because it's a class b sorry it's
supposed to be a capital h
that has view
all right like this
so let's import in home
from views
so from
dodge views
import
home
all right
so save it up and now
let's start our server
and see
all the errors i have made
fighters
manage the pui
run server
okay
oh
it seems you have started making
mistakes already so inside
the
model.wifi
i made some mistakes i were online 25
instead of chalford i said cha cha what
is wrong with this boy
i'm sure you guys caught that already
so
let's save it and wait for this
server to restart for us
is that there's another error again
what's wrong
what are we hearing over here
okay is it
out of chain related
what's going on what's going on
okay
custom user model
okay so i know why this is
beginning to [ __ ] up so inside because
you are using the abstractions that you
are supposed to provide inside
or provide our custom user inside the
settings that
urls for all right
so when you go down
go to the bottom part
so let me add some view comment or
settings
i know you know i can't spell
so we are going to add an odds
user
model
and this is going to be a reference to
call dot
custom
custom custom user all right like this
and said her null has no effect sorry
sorry guys i always make this mistake
so let's take out this now it can just
be blank
but
now there's no needed for a many too
many fields
okay so save it
then come here
and save this one too
let's go down and see what is going
whether we are still alive
i am getting some errors having said
before
what is these what is this
okay so i think i know where the error
is coming from
hey what's up what's going on so let me
clear the tub in office
and first let me make some migration
python
manage your pie
make migrations
if i get an error i'm going back to
school
so
python
managed the pie
migrate
i think this is what's going to solve
our problem
okay now let's run our server again
python manager.pi
run server
silva
i always get confused that i'm running
npm script and fighter by your ui
okay so you can see our problems are
solved okay so now let's go and see
whether the view we created is working
let me open a new tab over here
so localhost
you can see i am a level view so
48 88 is already open
so let's switch it to 8 000.
let's open it up
let's see what is going to happen
okay and we are we have a disaster so
you have the templates but you can see
the styling is not coming through
and the images two are not coming
through so we have a horrible one over
here okay so
before we do that let's let's
let's make some changes so you can see
inside there
for that uh the terminal down here it's
making some get requests to some asset
files and it's not having access to it
okay and i
i know where that whether errors i see
it's made and
a request to
get a style.css which does not exist
that's where
the the directory that's looking for
it's at so let's solve that issue
so
inside the uh what's the name
the
the templates directory we are going to
create a new file i'm going to call it
base
dot html
all right
let me change this thing
okay no worries
all right
then
you can change this thing
let's let's make some small changes over
here
so yeah you can change this to netflix
and we are going to add a block over
here
i'm going to call it title
okay so let's put some dash over here
all right
then the next thing that we need to add
is our
uh our css so link
going to our css so our css is inside
the static
what's in it the static directory over
here so we have to find a way of
bringing our static files here and
serving it okay so first we are going to
load in our
load
our static okay
all right so let's use our static over
here
all right so this is our static and so
now
you'll be able to have access to our
style.css which is inside the static
directory all right
then the next thing that we need is what
do we need again okay so we are going to
have
another block
called odess
so that if there any other lines that
are particular to the page that we are
visiting it will be rendered over here
all right
okay i think that makes sense then the
next thing that we need
is
we need what do we need what do we need
okay
so
we need another block called content
content
that is where our
all our content are going to go all
right
so this is it
i hope this makes sense all right
okay
so
now that we have our
base.html done it's
it's good
and let's see what do we need here we
don't need anything again so now let's
open our index.html file and we're going
to make some small changes to it so that
it's be able to use this this is the
html file we have used
and the other
and be able to utilize our style.css2
all right
so we are going to clear this part
click the top part here
and first you're going to extend
extends
base
dot html all right
then
the next thing that we need to add
is we want to load in our static so i'll
be able to
use it okay
all right so this is the title so let's
add our title to it okay so another
block
i'm going to call the blog the block is
called title so
so you can call this yeah you're passing
in home so that
to show netflix dash home
okay
so we can take up this
so
the other link that i was talking about
is this particular link here this link
is to
some icon
directory it's from icon ionic
ion icons i don't know how to pronounce
it but it's not all the pages that are
using it so we are going to use a blog
to render it for those
pages that need it okay so we are going
to store it inside there for this
what is
block
i'm going to move this thing up
all right
and
we are going to move this whole thing
here
let's move this whole thing here
this glass here
cut it
and bring it to
this one over here the base dot atm
offer
let's save it
then
go back
then we can take off this one these two
tags
and place the whole contents of the
the whole content of the file or
yeah of the file inside the contents
contains block
all right so
let me
copy
move the whole path down
go go go go go down
go down go down
my laptop is a little bit slow so
please forgive me guys
it's not intentional
okay so you can end here
so
at the footer part and let's move it up
okay so
when you're done we can clear this thing
off
these two
ones these two tags okay so let's save
it and now let's go back and go and
refresh and see whether it's going to
work
do you have any errors okay so you can
see you have netflix homes
you can see their home is now popping up
all right so you can see we have most of
our styling back again
because our styling is
working again but we have a problem
the problem is that our images are not
showing
there's supposed to be an image here
then an image here but they are not
showing i don't know why
but
i know why
because
you are referencing them directly from
the folder and they are not there so you
have to find a way of loading them from
our static okay
so when you scroll up
the images file we are going to start
from this place
this year
the static
so let's take up the assets here then
they're all inside the static file so
static
like this all right
then go down
click of this part
sorry
then
let's copy this part
make it static
all right
so there i think there are two or three
more down there let's do that quickly
so
when you scroll down
this there's this one there's another
one here there's another one down there
too
so let's take off just take off the
static in front there any and if you're
using
vs code
it makes it even easier okay
just highlight this here and type static
choose this you see it makes it very
simple
click on the star ticket that i set
again
all right let's love it last one i
guess the kids part yes this one that's
the last part
um what's the name
static what's the name
okay so
let's save it now let's go ahead let's
refresh
and see whether it's going to work
okay let's give it a few seconds
something that happened it's
okay so you can see our images are now
in you see we have our first parts
almost done
the face page is almost done guys if you
are new to the channel please subscribe
to the channel
if you are
if you are new if you are old please
like the video share with your friend
comment in the section in the comment
section below it's really going to help
me okay all right please support me out
all right
okay so this is it so you can see our
images are now
coming in we have our home page of
netflix
done
all right so let's jump let's let's go
on so
when you look inside when you go through
all the templates that you see that
you'll be using the
navbar
almost in order in order this one
in all the templates so it's it makes
sense that
we make this a partial then we import it
in or we include it in all of our
files okay
so let me cut this part off
and inside the template here
we are going to create a new directory
called partials
and inside the partial directory i'm
going to create a new
file called navbar
dot html
and inside it's the number that i copied
oh i cut
i'm going to paste over here
no changes to it the same thing the only
thing that you need to do is you have to
load in static all right
so i'll be able to have
access to it so static is loaded for
each and individual template
all right
so each template handles its own static
so load
so let's save it
then let's close it
you come back and make some changes
later on
okay so now let's include it over here
not included i'm going to include
partials
slash
navbar
sorry nava
dot atmo
all right
like this
let's leave some space so
it helps okay
now let's go back and refresh and see
whether there are any changes so this is
the original one without us
copying anything away
let's refresh
same thing no different oh wait let's
wait a little bit
the same thing no difference no changes
okay all right
hope you guys are following okay so the
next thing that i want us to do is let's
talk about the authentication part of
things okay the authentication
so
in this project you're going to use
almighty all ought
so jungle we are going to use django all
or to handle our authentication if you
don't know what all what is this is all
what so all that is an
authentication package that makes
authentication and jungle very simple
and very
uh like the standard it's it's it's it's
it means the standards
of authentication okay so it gives you
access to social authentication and
normal authentication too as well so
you just speak in store jungle all out
or this is their documentation i'm going
to link leave the link
inside the description below okay all
right all right guys so
please do a paper install of jungle or
if you have not
done it
i've already done that so i'm not going
to
go through that step again and i'm going
to need to add some changes
to the templates file they need you to
have this jungle
template
contest processor dot a dot request
it's already
inside our house already so if you
scroll up
this is
it's
maybe i've made some changes to it so
but it's needed so
it's already there it was provided by
the jungle dash admin
generator all right
and the next thing that we need is this
thing
this thing over here
so let's copy this over here
copy this
go back
this is how i live my life
okay
so if you read the comments
you're going to know what it individu
what
each individual import does all right
let me take off this one too
all right
then the next thing that we need to do
is sorry
is we need to add
what's the name
inside our static files you need to add
these three things these are
essential and the down one are based on
the social order you want to use
all right
let me close let me let me
minimize this one down here okay
so let's scroll up
let's scroll up
and let's go to
install apps installed up so
i'm going to leave a comment here third
party apps
i'm going to leave it down here
oh it didn't copy sorry guys
let's go and copy it again
copy
go back
paste the ticket
all right
so now you have added it
and it seems it's left with some one or
two stuff and you're done with
all out so you need to add a site id
equals to one and inside the url of py
far
you add this one
you have the spark all right
so i'm going to copy that path
and we just go and type in the site id
into
it so
site
underscore id
is go to one
and when you go into you go into the
root urls of ui file
i'm going to add the
url file
the path that i copied okay
but first i need to add a comma over
here before jungle subscribe
save that
and let's go back to our settings.poi
file again
all right so we are going to make some
changes to
us uh
our authentication so
all odds provide us with some
um some configuration that we can make
to make authentication so simple and
lovely
it seems i'm making the source for a lot
all right so
the first thing that i'm going to add is
the authentication method
so the authentication method
allows us to choose
which way
a user should log in either they should
log in with their email or they should
log in with their their username or
either username or email right
so
so
account authentication
method
and in this our app or in this our
project you are going to use email i
don't think
uh
all the name netflix is ever going to
use caesar name to log in
so you just want to be oh sorry it's
supposed to be an email
not in email
email
all right
right so the next thing that we need to
do is attend a
you want to make email
a required field so email accounts
email
account email required
request we create what how do we spell
it okay
required
i'm going to set it to true
sorry guys
the python true not
the other programming language too
all right
then you're going to set
authentication
account email verification sorry i can't
email
verification
i'm going to set it to none
a string on
not
python none okay and
the last two things that we need to add
is account
user
name
required
so that is going to
tell
a
all or twitter to require username when
a new site is registering or not and you
want to set it to false because
we don't want users to pass in
email uh their usernames when they are
registering all right
then
the last thing that i want us to do is
not related to all autobots it's related
to django itself which is the login
sorry
login
login redirect
url
and i'll we are going to pin it to slash
for the mean time all right
uh us usually it goes to something
something profile accounts for something
like that
but we are going to put you to
slash all right so with this done let's
see what our survives through our life
okay let me scroll down and see what
these other disaster we are in
okay okay okay
so it's saying that we need some okay so
when you look at the all odds
documentation
down here
it's asking for this required thing here
so the tool already has been added to
our installer by the jungle crate app
but we need to add this
site whatever the contrib sites
thing right
so scroll up
let's add it so
let's add it to it and save it
let's see what you see our server is
restarting again let's see whether it's
gonna work
okay so you can see it's working but we
need we have some migrations that we
need to make as soon as possible so
let's add our server
and clear the terminal
python manage
the pui
migrate
okay so it's going to migrate quickly
then we continue with our livestock
a few seconds more so now let's
run our surveying
py py
run server
sorry server
okay guys
all right so now that we have
we are down in this
so let's refresh
sorry sorry
let's refresh
okay so now let's go to our login part
you can see we have not even added any
router but you can go to our login you
have a fully login place which you can
log in log out and
other stuff so accounts slash login
just click there so you can see we have
a login here you can go to sign up
you can go to
i saw some forgot to password somewhere
okay let's go to sign in again
you can go to
sign in uh forgot password and you can
reset you see so all art gives us all
these functionalities baked in
okay so
the first thing i want to do is first
you want to change this
sign in and sign up
uh what's the name
how do i put a template or how it looks
too cody and we can let our users use
yes okay so first thing you are going to
override this team please the templates
for the sign in and sign up all right
okay
so
what are you going to do you are going
to override the template here okay so to
avoid all other templates the first
thing that you have to do is
that inside
your templates directory you are going
to create a new folder
oh sorry not a new file
my bad
a new folder
or a new directory and call it account
and inside account if you want to
override template that template for
login you're going to create a new
template and call it login if you want
to override the template for sign up
you're going to create a new template
and call it sign up so for us we are
going to move this our templates login
into
this directory over here all right so
now let's go back again
so as far as this was a login page
but
you're going to get a cody one but still
it's it's worth the explanation so so
now you can see we have a new
login
and this is it it's using my because
yeah but you know using what they
they based on html that's why it's not
looking beautiful
at all
okay so let's make it beautiful let's
make it beautiful
so let me close the stamina
open there
the templates happen let's make some
changes to it all right
okay guys so we are going to make some
changes to our
our templates here so
just like we did for the home view we
are going to clear this part
let's clear this one off
with us
so first you're going to extend
extend this part
and with this you're going to
go back
one directory then go
into get the base dot atml file because
build.html file is not directly inside
the account for that so you are going
back so i can have access to sa the next
thing you're going to have is the block
the block title
title
and here is going to be
login
so we can clear off this one here
these two things over here
i'm going to have another block
called odess
okay let's move this script up
into the block like this
okay
the next thing you're going to do is
you're going to surround the main
content or the
the content inside the body tag
in a block content
block content stack okay
so content
sorry content
oh what am i spelling
all right
if you know you can hire me at netflix
please contact
me oh guys
my next place is a very
it's it's worth to the price i really
enjoy the
application okay so
this is it so
let's go back and refresh and see
whether
we are going to have
some
something
so let's refresh i hope we don't get any
error
give it a few seconds a few seconds
okay so you can see
we have some then going on
first our logo is not coming in and we
are supposed to have some background
image it's also coming in so let's go
and fix that
so i told you that we are going to use
our navbar
throughout so we can include it also
here so let's take out this number
then let's include it
let's include it
so
i'm going to go backwards
then go into our parties
slash
navbar
dot html
no atm
like this
okay so the next thing that you need is
this thing here
the background image let's change it so
that it's it's referenced from our
static
so let's copy over
static like this
all right
so it seems that's all that what we need
is how loud we need all that we need
let's refresh again
and see whether you get an error
i knew we are going to get an error
because we didn't load in
our static let's go back
so let's load in static
okay with that done let's go back and
refresh
the flash
okay it means we didn't get any error
again
and where is it
voila
you can see
our
what's the name
another
is showing here
and our background image is showing here
beautiful beautiful as you can see
i did a good work with the styling
okay guys
so
one thing that you have to take into
consideration is that
the names here should match the name and
id here for the individual input
should match the one which would have
been provided for you if you are using
the original templates provided by
what's the name all out okay
so here we need to make here login
so the name is supposed to be sorry
the name supposed to be
uh
what's login and id login okay sorry
should have done this earlier on
okay
and let's save it
the next thing that i want us to check
is this
uh where we are going to render our
error messages if there is any errors
with
the email
with the authentication credential that
has been provided okay
okay guys so for us to be able to render
the errors here yeah i'm going to paste
in some code
shortly so this is it
so let's just take out this static
static error that i provided just to
so it's helping the styling okay
so
i think that the code that i pasted was
from
here
to here okay
this is it so this is going to check if
the form has errors if it has an error
it's going to create this div and it is
going to render their forms dot
non-filled errors okay
this is it all right
so
the next thing that i want us to is
let's say a person is on the homepage or
let's say he's watching a particular
movie
and want to go to the login i want us to
the user to be redirected back to the
place that they were
they logged in from okay
they logged in from so you are going to
add in some snippet of code to us well
inside the form
let me put it over here below this thing
so i have it already copied to my
clipboard so this is it
i think that's it
paste it over here
this is it okay
so let me
scoot over here a little bit sorry
okay so you can pause it and enter in
this thing so it redirects the person
back to where they clicked the login
from all right
so save it
and let's go back and test it again
yes
all right so let's try let's try logging
in
so let me use my
favorite email
okay so you can see
nothing happened it is because of
something that i know about
i am guilty about it so inside the form
uh on the form tag you are supposed to
specify which method
that we want to use so at the meantime
it is using get
which is not
the right way so it's supposed to be the
method is supposed to be set to post
all right
so let's go back and refresh it again
let's take out this thing from there
refresh
and i know you're going to get an error
so let me not
make us make that error face so inside
jungle for us to submit a form it's
supposed to have a csrf token
okay for security reasons so you're
going to add a csrf
talking to it
this way or else you're going to get an
error
let me refresh again
all right
so admin
and the super strong password admin
let's post let's let's log in and see
what is going to happen
what is going on what is going on
you can see
now
we have an error this is a dynamic error
that is coming in from the back and says
the email or password is specified is
are not correct okay so
something is going on over there so the
next thing let's go and work on the sign
up let's go and we're going to sign up
so the first thing that i want us to
change is
this thing before we go and continue
that i want us to
route
this link to the sign up page okay so
let's add a url here
so as a url
url
and it's going to go to
you know sign up
not to login sign up
just l sign up
oliver be serious
okay
this is it
this is it
now let's go back and refresh
let's refresh again
it's saying it does not exist
what is this
okay let's go back let's go back
sign up
excuse me
okay guys so it's apparently it's
supposed to be
account underscore sign up
all right save it
okay so no errors
no errors no errors no errors
our image is also coming in so you can
see when you're over now it's in a
sentence to account slash whatever
whatever so let's click on it let's see
what i have you see we are now on our
sign up now let's go back on the sign up
templating all right
so inside this the same thing that we
did for the login you're supposed to
have a file that is called sign up
inside this account file over here
so me being a wonderful person
and the official
jungle papa i am moving this
for that
the father i provided for you inside the
stata far inside
this account folder
all right
so now let's go and refresh and see
whether i'm going to get
taken out of what you are seeing here is
going to be different because
mind is also going to be cruddy
okay so you see mine too mine has a logo
and other stuff over here so let's
let's go and make some changes to it so
that it uses the base the html file and
the
asset files too all right
so
let's take out this part
let's extend
base
sorry you have to move back
the directory
based html
then the next thing
is let's load in our starting before we
make any error
let's load our static where's the load
vs code want to place my brain
okay the next thing that we need is
the block
title
and the title is going to be
oh [ __ ] another
okay
going to be not sorry
sign up sign up
all righty
the next thing i need is
another block
that is going to be called
block con block or this
let's move this into it
let's take out this part
what are we going to call it
yeah what's called the applause block
content
then let's move over the stain
into it like this and let's take off
this two over here
all right
so the next thing that we need to add is
the background
this background then
let's take off this asset
arrest references for our static
all right
the next thing that we need to add is
i want us to change this
redirect here so i sent us to
the
sign the login page okay
you're on the sign up so you have to go
back to the login so you are
going to go to account
and that's called login
save it
now let's go back and refresh
[Music]
okay
so you can see we have something now
we have something here
okay but another is not working let's
import in our nova sorry i forgot about
that
let's take out this thing and include it
include our
navbar from the partial
include
pass your house
so it's supposed to be a string
first you have to move back in
partials
slash
navbar
dot html
let's save it
go back refreshing
wait for a few seconds a few seconds
voila
that is it
so you have a sign up page also working
beautifully beautiful
okay so one or two changes then we are
almost done with this place so
just as the other one here is the the
names and the
this one should
be the same
so here is supposed to be password one
the name supposed to be password one
id
password one something like that yes
i think this is it to do the right one
and
we also want to
render
what's the name
our
our errors okay our errors instead of
having statically
typed over here where is it
this is it
let me take it out
and the code that i
pasted in from the previous code i'm
going to paste it again
same thing
so you can pause it and
type it in okay
all right
then the final thing is the redirect
the redirection thing all right
okay
let's put it
let's put it here
let me
get it for my
paste it over here
screw it over here so that you can see
scroll scroll
alrighty alrighty so i think that is all
that is that about that as far as that
is concerned all right
so
and the last thing that lasted i always
say the last thing i know done
let's add our csrf token
using a form so csrf
token and let's change this method
from get to post
to method is going to be post
all
right so now let's refresh
all right so you can see this beautiful
thing over here so let's try and login
and see whether you're going to get any
errors so
that is my second favorite password
hey email
let's click on login
are there going to be any errors
a few seconds more
and wonderfully we didn't get any errors
okay because you're not supposed to be
rendering this errors over here because
this is
the sign up form it's not giving us what
the name
the non-third errors it is giving us a
field errors okay so
we have to use those ones okay
so instead of using this one over here
let's take out all this one so yeah
sorry about that guys
i use this one instead let me push this
thing backwards a little so i have some
beauty all right
so there's the arrow that i'm going to
use
so let's refresh
then let's try again
i'm using a very short password so i
will get an error
to test whether the air functionality is
working
okay so you can see now that the errors
are coming say the password is very it's
too short it must contain whatever
whatever
so what yes so you can see
it's working so let's create a pass
let's create a new account
let's use
a better password so let's say test one
two three four
super strong password
test
one two three four
okay then let's load let's sign up let's
see whether it's going to work
um you can see
the password too is very common
so which password are you going to use
again
okay let's let's
let's change it up i'm going to use
kalakest
that's my password
now i don't think it's going to come on
kill artists
and it's also above its
killer
test let's log in and see sign up and
see it's going to work
okay so you can see we have successfully
signed up then we have already also been
redirected to
our
uh what's the name
the login the home page all right
okay so you can see there's it
so let's go back
and inside our navbar.atmo i want us to
do some quick
changes
some quick quick quick changes all right
so
we are going to add
another button
but we want to show
sign in if the person is not logged in
and sign out if the person is already
logged in
so if
request
dot user
dot is authenticated
and i've made that error over here
put an error
so the dot is supposed to be just simple
that is authenticated
then we want to show this one over here
or else
you want to show
another one that is similar to this one
i want to log out
so sign out instead
oh i have interchanged it
log out
so if the user is logged in we want to
show
log out
not the other way around
so let's move this one down
all right so now let's refresh and see
whether it's going to work
so you can see because we have signed in
we signed up and it signed us in that's
why we have seen the logged in okay
so let's work on the logos functionality
quickly
okay
okay guys so for us to
handle the logout you have to send a
post request to the back end which is
going to handle that for us to make a
post request we also need a form
even though uh
all odds provide a way of
signing out on a get request which will
just make a request to the end point and
to send a person out
it is not advisable to sign out a user
using a get request
you can find more about it inside
jungle's documentation okay so
gets request is not made to make changes
on a resource on the
server
but a post request is supposed to do
that so it's it's more advisable to use
a post request so first we are going to
create a form over here
in a form with a method of
post
the action is going to be handled by
ourself
okay
so i'm going to have a post
and you're going to move this button
inside it
okay
we are going to change
the type
okay the type is already submitted don't
worry about the type
so
you're going to change the action the
action the action
oh god
action
and
i'm going to
pass it the url
to account
account underscore logout
okay
so
guys we need to change this thing
make it tomorrow
sorry sorry sorry sorry about this
this way
all right
this makes sense
then you need to provide a csrf token
of course you're using a form of jungle
cry
csrf token
i think that is
it
okay let's save it
then go back
let's refresh
and see whether
i'm going to have any errors
okay so
let's log out
what happened
you see we are logged out
so you can sign in again all right so
the log out functionality is working
so guys we are almost done with the
authentication part of
this project let's click ok so let's
make this 10 go today
what's the name
uh
the sign up page okay so that it makes
more sense
so
down here
the button that's goes to
i'm going to wrap it and hr without
points too
now points to the url of the login
is going to be account
and that's called login
okay so
let's move this whole
happy wa into it
let's save it
go back
then
refresh differentiate
okay
so give it
a few seconds that
my computer doesn't blows up
let's click on
it
let's see where it sends us
and voila it sends us to login
so
we can log in and see whether it's going
to work
the account that we created was what's
the name
a b
dot
be.com
and the password was killer
test
let's
see whether i wanted to get logged in
okay so it seems we have logged in
we are able to log in successfully
no errors now
okay so you can see you have a logout
button over there
okay
for some reason since my
was the fonts are not working
because this is not the font i used
me fix that and let me check why that's
you know okay guys so i it seems i know
why the why the fonts are not working
are not looking great
so inside the base.html file
why is it where's that guy this guy
you need to add
one class today
total listing here
add
fonts
and that's called a front dash primary
the primary
yes fonts does fonts that's primary and
also below the block here add in the
scripts
this small javascript
i don't want to scare anyone
so
this small javascript i'm going to need
it later okay so let's just put it in
for the meantime
okay let's save it now let's go back and
refresh and see whether it's going to
look a little bit nicer and closer to
the real netflix
homepage
okay
now you have a vieda
what's this
okay so now it has loaded in the
fonts and it looks more
beautiful beautiful beautiful nice one
nice one okay
so the next thing that we want to do or
work on is the profile page oh yes the
the
the view that is going to show us our
profiles all right
so let's go back to visual studio code
okay guys so let's jump into the views
and write
the view for
our what's the name the profile page
okay so you can close this
page.html
index.html you can go sign up and log
log in to can go down
sign up
okay so now
let's go back to our views the pi file
so
i'm going to create another
view
so we're going to call this class
class
the class profile
list
so that's where we are going to list our
profiles so it's going to also inherit
hey it's view
sorry sorry guys
then
the next thing that you need to get is
the
the def
uh
get define our get method so self
we're taking self requests
acts
and quarks
then
the next thing i want to get is the
profiles
so profiles
the profiles of that our our current
user okay our user that is assessing the
the
current the profile page sorry
so we are going to get it from the
request
dot user
dot profiles
that is the folder we just added to our
custom user
then because it's since it's a
many-to-many field we can call that dot
all on it so we get all defaults all the
proof outs
and we are going to
return
a render
a render of
our request
and
what's the name there template name is
going to be profile
less
dot html so when you check the templates
which you clone you see a profile and
there's it
okay and you're going to pass some
context
arguments along so we're going to pass
a contest
called profiles sorry profiles
whatever i spend if you can spell
profiles okay
i i wish it was javascript where you
just type profiles that i'm going to do
the magic for you
so
they are referencing this profile okay
so this is it this is the view that is
going to give us our profile list
but the problem is that
if a a person that is not signed in try
to assess this
this endpoint or this view we are going
to get an error because that person is
going to be an anonymous user an
anonymous user instance does not have
this profile instance on its profiles
instance or the post
profile false on it sorry guys okay so
you have to protect this route
so you have to make it
open to only signed in users or logged
in users okay so from
jungle
sorry it's supposed to be jungle
jungle dot
coin trip
contrib.ot
decorators
i'm going to import
the login required so the login required
the creator
all right
okay so since you are using a class base
we can't directly decorate this
this view
so
we are going to use
the method that created to this to
to decorate the dispatch
the dispatch method
okay so
i'm going to pull down to from
jungle
dot
corn trip a dot you tell sorry
uterus
dot
the creators
import
method
okay method the creator like this
and since you want to
decorate the dispatch
you are going to place at the crater
here so
the art symbol you are going to use
method
the creator
all right
and then
the creator that you are using is the
login the creator login required
the creator and the
name of the method i want to create is
the dispatch
okay so let's save it
now yeah you should uh provide a path or
a route for this view so let's go to
our urls the py file inside the core
directory
then let's import profile
list
then
go to patch
and you are going to provide it
this
sorry profile
sorry
oh what's wrong
okay
then
i'm going to provide a profile
list
dot as view
okay
hope you guys are following
then the name we are going to give it as
profile
and that's called list
okay
so save it there
uh are we right
i guess so there's no error
or there's an error because this is not
highlighted let me see where that is
still alive
okay the server is still alive
let's go to that endpoint and see
whether
it's going to work
slash profile and you can see we are
logged in okay
oh shhh
slash profile
and you can see
we have
something but it's not looking great so
let's let's work on that template
quickly
so let's go to profile list
profile list
that one is going to be very simple
quick quick quick quick
since you have seen it already
it's just going to extend
base.html
add another block here
block
title
i'm going to call this profile
let's take off this once here
call this block
content
let's move this whole thing
go down go down
let's end on the section
move this thing up
okay let's take out these two
then
let's take out this nav bar
and include
include the one from partials
slash navbar
now by the html okay
save it
then let's go back and refresh
and see what happens
okay okay so you can see
you have something going on over here
something going on beautiful
beautiful beautiful all right so this
one's uh this this are static dips so
you're going to take those those ones
off
and you're going to loop over
the ones that we are going to bring
okay
let's take
this this i'm just going to leave just
one okay
just one all right thank you
i'm going to run a for loop okay
so
for
for profile
in profiles
like this
okay
like this
and you want to make this thing
an itch an a tag
okay so that will be able to
for the mean time i'm going to make it a
hash
for the mean time
okay
so when you click on the div it's going
to send us to
it's going to allow us to use that
particular profile okay
all right
so i want you to add in this template or
this small html inside this dev
yeah
this thing over here so
we get the profile name then we slide it
so we just have just one letter and
below it we place the
what's the name
the profile name the profile name so we
have like if it's
the
the profile name is altered there we are
going to have a capital or a big one and
below it you are going to have a trade
below it okay
so let's add this view class flex
flex dash call
i'm going to give it first column and
justify
the center
align center
align center like this right
and save it
let's go back again
let's refresh what you are going to see
you won't like it
because there will not be anything over
here okay yes because our user doesn't
have any profile yet
that's why it's not showing anything
currently all right
so let's go back
hey so we are going to log out over here
and see what's going to happen whether
you're going to see this page or it's
going to
take out from this page
you see it takes us back to the login
page okay
okay that's nice so let's try since you
are logged out let's try going to that
profile
profile page again
profile
like this
let's try going to the route again
and because we need to log in before we
need to be re
logged in
uh what's the name
to be logged in before you have access
to that page or that view
it has brought us to the login page okay
so let's log in and see whether we can
go there now be
okay
let's pass in
keller
killer
test
and voila we are going to be directed to
our page our home page all right
so
the next thing i am going to work it on
is creating
a new
profile so that if a user comes and has
no profile
that him or her can go to
the profile page okay
but before we do that i want us to
add some changes to the view
so
to the home view so if a user is logged
in already we want that person not to
see the index page but whenever it tries
to access the home page you should send
them to the
profile page okay
that one makes more sense because what
is already on the
homepage is not
it's not something that should be shown
to someone that is already logged in all
right
so if
request
the user is
authenticated
i think you're supposed to be a request
not request
then you're going to return
a redirect
okay so i'm going to click on it it's
going to auto import redirect redirect
for me okay
so
you have to add it to your imports
okay so you want to
be
redirected to core
hyphen
it's not hyphen
semi colon
profile
profile underscore list okay so this
year i'm using a reverse
a reverse url okay
so let's save it
and
since you are we are logged in you said
let's try accessing the home page
let's try accessing the home page here
just slash
you see it's
okay
since you have some
crazy errors down there
what's went wrong
oh sorry it's supposed to be
8 000.
i'll show you guys what's that
let's try refreshing
since you are logged in you see it's
redirected us to
the profile page beautiful beautiful
beautiful
all right guys
so
let's go and work on the
profile crates
okay guys so
let's create
let's work on the profile crates
view
so let's go down
so so it's going to be class
profile crate
okay so it's going to inherit from view
okay so you're going to have
a get method
i'm going to take in serve
requests
they can act some quarks
okay
then
inside the get request you want to
return a form
that form is going to help us create
their profile okay
so let's say you're going to have
you let's just leave a comment form
for
adding
not for creating
creating
a profile
right then let's return
a render so return
render
we're going to render the request
and return the the profile create
html
all right
so let's save it
then let's go and add it to the url
so
first let's import it in let's import it
in
profile crates
so here's supposed to be a capital okay
profile create like this
then i'm going to use a path
i'm going to send it to profile
slash create
slash
then you are going to use the profile
create
create dot as view
with the class base
view
so the name is going to be
profile crates
as you just guessed
all right
all righty so let's go ahead and test it
out
let's check let's first check with our
survives our life
okay it's still alive let's go and test
it out
so profile
slash creates
okay so you can see we have something
over here so we have to again edit our
our what's what's it called our template
so templates
all right where is this profile create
just close this terminal down
so first
you are going to do the usual stuff
let's take out these things
extends
extends
base.atml
then
we need another block
title
i'm going to call it leave
that test
proofer
creates
supposed to be
capital profile
this looks nice
let's take out this
the stacks
take out this one too
okay
then now you can have another block here
called block
content
all right so now let's grab everything
inside it
inside the section
the exception of those two last two tags
send it into
the block content
take out these two
okay
so now we have to
take out this navbar then include our
enough partial
fascias
slash navava
that's hcml
okay now save it
let's go and give it
clear
okay something is coming through
it seems there's supposed to be an image
behind it
okay that's how it's going to look
i think that is supposed to look
i feel like there's supposed to be an
image behind it so let's just add an
image
let's use image as a background for it
okay so let's first load static
and
the section here
let's add an inline style
that is going to take in a background
background dots image
that is going to be a url
to
static
and we are going to use background
organ.jpg let me check the static files
sorry
so i've done this beforehand
my laptop is freaking slow
background underscore netflix.jpg
jpg you know
okay
and here let's add the classes let's add
bg
dash cover
all right
now let's refresh
and see how it's going to look like
all right this one looks more beautiful
nice
such a nice one
okay so
the next thing that you are going to do
is you are going to work on the form on
the form that you are going to
use to create the
the profile okay
so inside
our
our core
directory create a new file called forms
of
ui from the pui
all right
all right so yeah i'm going to import
one or two stuff so from
jungle
jungle
what did i saw
dot
jungle.
oh what's this forms
import
model form
right
and we are going to import our model to
the from dot model
import
a profile
that
what you're going to use oh see it's
supposed to be dot models
okay so you're going to create a class
called profile
form
if i can spell profile
profile form
which is going to inherit from
the models
the model form
like this
then i'm going to give it a class meta
sorry
sorry about this
combined thing it's supposed to be class
meta
and
below i'm going to specify the model
that's where i transfer method
model is going to be equal to the
profile model that we just
brought in
then we are going to specify and exclude
okay that's the field that should be
excluded and the folder i want to
exclude
is the
uuid field
so that the ui is
generated dynamically
from the back end all right don't worry
about that
you don't have to worry about that okay
so
now we are done with our the form for
creating our profile
so let's import it in and use it here
inside our view
okay so
first let's import it in
from
what's the name
from.forms
import
profile form
oh
bad
from proof of import profile form okay
so now we have our profile form here
so the next thing that we want to do is
we want to use our profile form so from
i'm going to create an instance of form
of that profile form so
profile form
then instantiate it and i'm going to
pass it along
opposite along inside
as a contest argument right
all right
i hope
it makes sense all right so this is it
this is our form now so this one is just
the guest method so it doesn't make any
doesn't make much
changes
most of the functionality is going to be
inside
the post method okay
so let's save it and now let's go and
make some changes inside our crate
template
so you are supposed to have
two fields
one which is going to be a select and
the other which is going to be
uh
so
an input field the input folder is going
to take in the name so here is supposed
to be just name a profile name
so the name here you see i've been
changing the name and the id name so the
name here should correspond to the field
name
the name that was given to the fold and
the id should be id underscore the field
name you get it all right
so here is going to be id
underscore name
like this
and here is going to be
id underscore age limits
if you check the model you see that
that's how they are called
limit age underscore limit
yes it's going to be
age underscore limits like this
all right
this is it's
okay now let's add
our method
today
to the form
which is going to be a post
then let's add our csrf token
all right this is it this is it
okay we are going
so let's we can close this thing here
let's close it down
then the form
then let's go back to our view again
so with the get method we are we are
done with it you don't have anything to
do with it so the next one you are going
to focus on is now the post method
we're going to have a death
for post
it's also going to take in
self
request
and axe and cracks
axle crocs
then
you are going to create
the form instance again
another form instance
of the profile
not mine oh
sorry profile form
but this time around we are going to
take in the request post request.post
or none
uh if this is going to help us get to
the
uh the data
that has been posted from the front end
here so that is going to be stories that
a request request.post or none
all right
that means if there's nothing inside it
that's what is going to be the noun all
right
or if there's nothing like a post
there's no post right
so first i'm going to check if the form
is valid
if the form is valid form underscore
valid
if i can spell valid draw
then
if it is valid we want to what let's
first print
let's print form dot
claim data that is going to give us
the values of
the form all right
from that clean data
and when you are done you want to return
a render
as usual
oh jungle cry
if
should i return a render or a redirect
oh you have to return a response that's
what i want to see
and then you have to return a response
so our response is going to be a render
we are basically going to do the same
thing as this let me just copy it
to save some time
same thing
like this
so save it
let's go back
to the form
and let's refresh this thing
so
let's pass it a name let's pass it or
trade dev
and the maturity level want it to be all
then
let's send a post
okay so the post has been done let's go
and check inside our terminal whether
the values where
so you can see the values came in this
is it so the form was valid and it's
printed the clean data so you can see
the name here and the age limit here as
for
okay
so since we have those values we can now
go ahead and create the profile
now
okay
so instead of just printing it let me
just comment so you have it
so you can go to profile
so i'm going to create a new profile
instance okay
so i'll just auto import it
so you can see it has been imported up
here for me
okay so you have to import it in
if you are not using visual studio code
so you don't have the auto import
feature
then you are going to do object
object dot create
and you are going to spread the the
values that you are going to get from
the
the value that you are going to get from
the clean data okay so let's copy this
thing here
let's just type it
let's not be let's not be lazy
so we are going to spread it
so because the dictionary he used to
asterisk
then crates
so it's supposed to be theory
supposed to be two not theory okay just
two yeah they're two so
i'm going to spread
i need to go back to some spelling
school or something like that from that
clean data
like this all right but we are going to
store the profile that is going to be
created
inside a variable
called profile
okay
so
when we have
this profile like this
that has been created for us
so if it is that it's able to
successfully create the profile then we
want to what redirects the
the user
to the place where they are going to
choose
they are going to choose what they are
going to choose their profile okay so
if profiles they are checking if their
profile was created and it is not known
if profile
you are going to
return
a redirect
sorry redirect
and the numbers are going that you are
supposed to redirect them to the place
that they watch their movies straight
but because you have not yet created it
you are going to
first redirect them to the profile page
where you choose your profile okay so
profile
sorry
what's
was there
so
where you are redirecting them is core
you are using a reverse url so
prefer
profound as for list
okay like this
so this is where we are redirecting them
to but one thing that we escaped was
that before somebody would be able to go
to the place where they created the
profile that person is supposed to log
in so we are going to do the same thing
as we did for the profile list
we are going to protect our routes
like this or else if a user that's not
signed in comes in to create
a new profile there will be danger
it'll be a big problem
okay so now the profile has been created
now the profile has been created here
and we are redirecting if the profile
has been created
but this profile is created and it is
not associated with any user yet
so for us to be able to associate it
with the user we are going to get inside
here before we do the redirect we are
going to
get to the request
dot user
then you check the profiles
we get to the profiles here then we add
to it because the main too many a
thought use add okay we are going to add
daft profile to it
uh us it will just be existing but it
will not be related to depot
user okay
you add it to it beautiful
then now you can save it i'm going to
test it out
okay so it seems everything is
fine and perfect
so first let's refresh this thing
okay
so
what's let's creates
for true dev
no
like this and the maturity is also
let's click click on this
submit
let's see what's going to happen
okay so you see we have been
brought to
our home page i've worked with a profile
place a profile page where we can select
a profile but it seems you have some
weird styling over here let's think
that's quickly
it looks too ugly
okay so where did you go wrong
so so so so
justify center ally center
let's add a text center and see what is
going to happen
i don't know why that's happening
but we will find out very soon
okay so that was it so just add a text
center
so here then it's going to work it's
going to look beautiful now so at first
there were no
profile here but now you can see
there's a profile here so now let's we
are going to work on
clicking up on the profile and it's
sending us to
the
to the watch view okay
where we can select a movie and watch it
okay
okay guys so now we are able to create
profiles and now display them here but
we left out to antonia we didn't link up
the url
that helps us to create the
profile to this button here so let's do
that quickly
so inside a profile list html dot html
come into this diff yeah
then let's surround
the button with an anchor
an anchor tag
that is going to have
let's
let's leave some space in between it and
let's move the bottom
into it
let's move it up
then
now let's use our url
so i think it is called
dots
a column creates
a profile crate sorry guys
profile
underscore crates
okay so let's save it
let's go back and refresh
okay
so let's refresh
okay so now
seems
there's something wrong somewhere okay
so that's nice it's working
okay okay so it's working it's working
it's working perfectly so let's go back
so we are done with the
the profile list area so now what you
want to do is that when the user comes
to this profile list and he or she
chooses a profile i should send them to
the
the page that is going to list all the
movie for them to choose the movie in
which which they want to watch okay so
let's work on that so that one is going
to be our movie list
it's going to be like a movie list
view or something like that okay
so let's go let's jump into our
view.pyfar
so you can close this to here
this to
files
let's close them
close this one to
okay
basically download that so you can move
to the bottom and create
create our new
class based views
so we are going to call that class
oh no
what is this sorry guys
supposed to be a class
class watch
oh it's supposed to be a copy file
copy firew okay
and you are going to
inherit
the view
then i'm going to define a get
a dev get
a get method
and you're going to take case of
requests
i'm going to take in
profile id that is going to be that id
of
the
the provider that was created okay or
the provider was selected okay to be
right
okay
then
the next thing that you want is
accent quarks okay
okay all right
so
now
the next what you are going to do
i will be saying the next thing in the
next penalty so
pardon me for that so you are going to
try
i'm going to use a try catch statement
all right
all right so
let's get into this
so
hey i said try cats try accepted with
javascript
has not flooded my brain so i'm going to
try and get to the
the profile the profile which is the
profile id that was provided
okay
so
i'm going to use profile
dot
objects
dots
get
so
we are using a try except cards because
if this profile does not exist it is
going to show
a it does not exist error
so that's why you are using the try try
except block so that you'll be able to
handle the errors
uh well okay
so we are going to get it to the uuid
okay the uid is going to correspond to
our profile
id
like this
okay cool all right so now you we have
our
our profile okay we have our profile
so what you want to do is that you want
to gather all the movies from the
database all right
so
it's going to be movies
oh what am i spelling
my computer is freaking slow
movie
begins gets paid
sorry about us guys
look at what's happening
okay guys so it's supposed to be
movies so guys you can see the shadow
i'm going to just
to
to come out to this video okay so please
if you are new to the channel please
kindly subscribe to the channel
if you are oh yeah already subscribe
please
like the video okay
please i i really cherish it okay so we
are going to filter
the movies that already exist inside the
database
and you're going to filter with the age
limit so that we don't
provide if the account or the profile is
a
a kids profile we don't send it
our dot movie is okay so we are going to
filter it today
the the all the name
the profile
age limit okay so i'm going to get it
from the profile so you if you remember
the profile has age limit on it and so
you are going to use that one to help us
filter so we are going to get the age
underscore limits
like this
then when you are done
i'm going to
check for one thing that if
okay so now we have a profile but we
don't know whether the profile belongs
to
the particular user that is
currently assessing it so we want to
check if that profile is inside the
current reset or the user that is
accessing our that page
list of profiles okay so you're going to
check that so
say if profile
not
in
request
dot user
dot
profiles
dot or
okay
if it is not in it
then we want to
cause a re redirect
of course i redirect
and you're going to send the redirect to
i'm going to send a redirect to call
but a column profile and
underscore list
that is where the
list of profiles are at okay
if
it is in it or
i'm going to
return
a render
that has a request
sorry guys request
request
and
pass is going to use the
movie list
templates that's already been prepared
for you
and you are going to pass along it
past it's with a contest
it's a contest
dictionary which is going to have our
movies okay
all right
movies
what it would have
sorry hence they are going to reference
this movies over here all right
so
but if
there's an error
or let's say if you are not able to find
a profile which is the probable error
that can
that can happen
so
profile the profile
model has
this
does not exist
does not exist error on it so we can use
that one as the exception okay
does not exist
does not exist
so
if it does not exist you also want to
do the same thing as this
you want to return
the user to
the profile
the profile
list all right
so
let's save it up
then let's go back
um
let's see what our server store
is still running all right all right
it's still alive so now you have our
view here so let's add it to our our
urls the py file
okay so it's going to be a path
that is going to have
a watch
and it's going to take in
a string
that is our profile
and that's called id
okay
so the act that you provided for the
view should correspond to
the name that you provide over here okay
so i called it profile id that's right
it's been called profile ideas over here
okay so and you're going to use the
watch
i'm going to use the watch and i'm going
to call it
as you
on the model
oh
on the view
you are going to give it a name of
watch
okay
so you have to import it here as usual
you're going to land in an error
watch
okay
so you can save it up but before you go
and test it out there's one thing that
we missed out you're supposed to protect
that view
from
uh for only logged in users
alone
so
i'm going to copy this
this method decorator over here
copy this
then send it down
this laptop of mine is very weird
that's what i have so i have to make the
videos for you guys too so
now let's save it up and let's go and
try it out
but there's no way of us
sending this profile or linking this
profile to the view that we just created
so let's go and make some
slide changes inside the profile list
templates
so where is that profile is templates
profiles does the die
okay so the change that i want us to
make is that we want to add a url here
that is going to
redirect us to the profile page
to the watch page okay
so let's add a url here
it is going to use
call
colon watch
and you are going to pass
the profile
id
as
the profile
dot uu
id okay the profile here is the current
profile we are looping over
the current
object that we have
from this profile okay profiles list
okay i hope it's clear
so let's save it up
and let's go back and refresh
okay so
now when you hover open this now so you
can see now you have a watch
if you look down here
let's let's just click on it and go to
that page
so now you can see now you are able to
be you are redirected to a new page
by since you have an error
this in one argument whatever whatever
whatever
so it seems you made an error
somewhere
so what happened so let's check our url
it's called profile id profile
underscore id so let's check our view
so that that's the what i was talking
about it's from
there is from that place
let's profile underscore id
what happened
it says
what takes one positional argument
but two was given
we'll give it a we'll give it to the two
oh
my brain is beginning to get tired
well where is this error coming from
i know my laptop has become incredibly
slow that
i can't even
let me check check check check check
check check
oh
my bad sorry about that
i'm sure you guys got that
i'm supposed to
instantiate it
so now let's refresh testing again
okay so now you can see
we have
some templating errors over here so
let's
it's working just the template has to be
fixed
okay so let's go into there
let's see the profile let's you add down
the profile list so
you can shut it down
okay guys so open up the movie let's
template
so i think it is to be a good idea if we
work on the template for the three last
ones left that is going to be the movie
detail
the movie list and the
show movie okay
let's let's
let's work on those three then we'll get
back into our view again
it's you're not supposed to keep long on
that so
we'll finish that quickly
okay so
this is the show movie so let's start
with the show movie let's start by
taking out the distance
let's take out it
and now let's extend
understand
a base
dot atmo
they are going to have another block
below
that is going to be called
title are going to have
a movie
like this
okay
so
you can take out this one these two over
here
then you're going to have another block
i'm going to call it others
we are going to move in these two
these two
into it
all right
the last thing i'm going to do is the
block
content
okay
so
now we can take away
what was this
can take away this part
with the inclusion of the nav bar so
from the navbar to the head
like this
and take away the bottom part
last two tags
we are going to move
the main
into
the
contents the block contents
and i'm going to include
include the navbar
include from partials
dot navbar
dot html
okay
let me save it okay so
i think we are done with the show
show movie so you can close that one
down
it's you can you can even
do it quickly yourself but i just
want to do it quickly so that we just
take our answers out we just be writing
our views and focusing on
better stuff
okay
so
let's delete
this i'm going to extend
base
dot atmo
okay
then the next thing we need is a block
title
the same is your stuff
i'm going to place in
detail
page
let's take all these two
over here
another block
i'm going to call it odis
i'm going to move the script tag into it
all right
the final thing i am going to have is
the block contents and the navbar so
let's clear
the number
away with the
head tag and the
whatever whatever the body tag
okay so
i'm going to have a
block
content
okay so we are going to move everything
inside this
let me
aha this is all i want
let's move it into it
all right so
everything beneath this thing has been
already copied and added to
our base.html file so we don't even need
it here again
come close you can delete it
all righty
nice one
so you're done with that one two so you
can close it
but you'll be making some changes
when you get today so don't worry don't
worry about those ones those changes
so
change
okay
here that's my laptop is v8
oh guys
so
this is the last changes we need to make
so let's delete this one extend
this
dot html
then you're going to have another block
now it's going to be called title
i'm going to open it enjoy netflix
enjoy
netflix
like this
let me get away this leg dog
and
let's have a block
on this
this thing is stressful
all right
i think we are almost done so let's get
away
this one here
with the nav bar
and let's
did we include another here i don't
think so
okay as i thought as much we should
include the number inside
the
movie detail so let's include it first
so include power shields
so it's supposed to be a string
partials
stars nav bar
that's html
okay i guess you're down with you
let's check so let me just confirm
something from the show movie
[Music]
okay so this partial is supposed to be a
string
supposed to be a string
before we land in another error
okay so
let's continue it to the movie list
trying to move as fast as i can
as i can move
so you're going to have another block
called content
the block
content
okay
let's close
or minimize this main
tag
they'll move everything into
the block content
nice one
so you can take away this
two tags
then re-expand it again because we are
going to make some magic in here
all right
so now let's save it
then go back and refresh and see whether
we're going to have our
page
working
we are going to land in an arrow
okay so you can see
staff are coming through
but we are not getting an image our
image here so i had a static image
over there
so let's fix that
oh where am i
okay so it's going to be a background
image okay this is it
is it
so first let's take away
the assets
let's wrap an aesthetic around this so
we will need to
load in our static file
all right
so
so we need to load in our static file
right up here
so load
static
we'll start tech like this
then
you can go back and refresh and see
whether a magic will happen
or not
and i can see the number is also not
appearing did you forget to include it
what is happening
let me refresh again
what's on f is happening
let me check my console
[Music]
i'm sure the file doesn't exist or
something like that
i knew it
i forgot to add those files to
it
okay
so sorry about that
but i don't know why the number is not
showing oh you forgot to include the
number okay i thought that's much
so let's include the number
enough bar
dot etml
so you can save it
then
you have to go but to that image that
it's not there so i'm going to freeze
this recording then add that email image
to the static file okay
okay guys so you can see i've added the
image to it so when you check the
the complete project you are going to
find this image
added to it okay
so let me close that one
and let's go back and refresh and see
whether you're going to get tense as you
want it
[Music]
first refresh
okay so
now we have
this thing but you have some styling
issue since this
styling is not coming through so
i think i know what the error is where
the error is coming from
so that particular button
which is display i'm going to add an ins
a star is
inline style in lifestyle
so it's going to be a color
of
black
okay
i think that's the only
one that needs it okay yes
so let's save it up
okay
this
is going to be our last refresh before
we continue what you are
going to continue
okay so now you can see everything
popping up nicely so this is where
you're going to list our movies
so we take the movies from our
from our back end then we are going to
list it over here okay
okay guys so
let's do that
what are we going to do
we're going to loop over the movies okay
so the movies are rendered with this
this dev over here so you are going to
get away all the this below and you are
going to leave only one just one
whereas you are going to use a for loop
to provide it
oh sorry sorry
so delete all of them and leave this
particular one the one that has the
image in it okay the one that has the
image in it
so we're going to take this off
i'm leaving the one with the image
because it has some styling that i need
okay so
just delete those ones without the image
all right
and you're going to run a for loop
on it
so it's going to be a for loop
i'm going to follow the house movie
movie in movies
and with each move we are going to
create an anchor tag so that will be
able to move to the at the detail page
of a particular movie okay
so for the mean time going to leave it
as an
hash
then
i'm going to wrap it around this
fire this
this div over here okay
so if you quite remember each movie has
a flyer so the flyer is what you are
going to
place inside the div
all right
so here
we are going to
render out
our image
or the flyer
for us to render out the flyer we are
going to have movie
dot
flyer
and we want the url
for that particular flyer okay not url
url
okay
so this is it you save it
now let's go back and refresh
see what's going to happen
a few seconds more okay so yeah then
so we scroll down and voila we have no
movies so there's nothing rendering here
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
pause the video then create a
super account then go into the jungle
database
the jungle admin then add some one or
two movies to
the to the back end okay
so it's not it's not anything huge
that's why i'm trying to make it you'll
let's create it together i don't want
you guys to miss out anything
my machine is just true
and it's loose i wanted to do it off of
side
but you let's do it together so that you
you have a full a full view of
everything
happening
okay so we are going to create
a super user okay
so we are going to do that with python
manage
the pui
create super user
okay
we are going to give it
let's use only
i'll try dev
let's give it something simple after my
brain is diet a at a
dot com
admin the password is admin
password is going to be admin
yes
okay so now let's play so now let's go
and use
our
jungle admin
solo car host
was 8 000
slash admin
so now let's login
so
i'm going to call a at a
dot com
the password is admin
oh
okay so it's logged in
so what we want to do is
where are we
wonderful we want to add movies but we
have not added the
the movie database to
our
our admin okay so let's do that so let's
go into core
i'm going to add our models to the
admin so the in the admin is the py file
let's go into that made up your file
i totally forgot
for what's about those steps so from
both models
imports
imports what's the name of the model
movie
then
also import
um profile
and last but not the least custom
custom user
and i totally forgot about this video
all right
so
i'm going to add it to our admin so
admin.site
dot register
is going to have movie
copy down
i'm going to make change
distance i want to move further my
laptop is laying me down
oh what's this
so it's going to be profile
see what it also
it's doing with me
so yeah video
and yeah
custom user
all right
i think we are good to go now
all right so let's go back to our admin
and give it a refresh again
okay so now you can see those things
over here
so
first we are going to create a video
the video is going to be linked to a
movie so
it's totally cool just follow along
let's create a video we are not going to
give it any title we are going to choose
some dummy short videos that i
downloaded from youtube so
what did i call them
i placed them somewhere
where did i place this things
short short short short video this guy
okay
so save it
save that particular movie instance
then now go to the movies
the video registers and i can't create a
movie instance
the f list
the f list
let's put some dummy os
at halftime
so it's going to be a single movie
and i'm going to choose one
then
i'm going to use the f list
a limit is all so let's save it
now we have a single movie instance
inside our database so let's go and
refresh it
let's refresh our homepage again so you
can see now you have nothing there but
let's refresh it again
okay
since you have a problem
let's log out
you can use our previous
our previous user
sorry about that guys
the images are huge so it's
it's makes
it slow to render
so it was using kojo
that's good.com
okay
first
so let's login
you want to go through the process of
creating another profile again
so okay so now we have a profile so
let's use it
okay so let's go and see that i have a
movie down here
okay so you have a movie down here
right since you're having some error
with our image
so let's check that one
it's
out
some
let's just try refreshing it again
wow why is it
why do not work in
so let's
let's change
let's inspect this
okay guys so it seems i found the error
it's from here it's not supposed to be
movies supposed to be movie
okay so let's save it
go back
refresh testing again
okay so you can see the image is coming
through
over here okay
so now you have
where you can list that movie so we need
to now make a detailed page okay so now
you can also expand upon it i i did it
myself
i've already done but i want to leave it
as a challenge for you guys
where you are going to send a single
video that is going to be a showcase
uh that is going to be the showcase
movie okay
so i'm going to
extract just one movie from here from
the filtered movies here now going to
use it as your showcase movie instead of
using the static
the static uh
showcase movie over here i'm going to
use that one as your showcase movie so
try that one out and let me know your
solutions down there inside the comment
section below okay i did it for myself
and it was very simple so i believe you
guys can do that so the next thing i am
going to work up on is
the detail page that when a user clicks
on this
this movie it should send him to the
detail page where he or she is going to
see all the details about this
particular movie
and then you can click open it to go and
watch it okay
so let's jump back into visual studio
code
and go into our views okay as usual
okay so let's create a
movie a detail page
so let's go down
let's create a new class
called
show movie
detail
let's make this
the capital
and it's going to inherit from
the view
okay so the next thing that i'm going to
do is you're going to
define a get method
i'm going to be taking self
taking request
and taking
the movie id
we underscore id
and the last thing is going to take in
the
axe
axe
and quarks
all right
okay so
what you are going to try is you are
going to try and get to the movie
the movie id and the movie with the
movie id okay so i'm going to use a tri
except
block
so that we don't get any
error so let's clear this thing off
i'm going to try
do it in a movie
variable you are going to get a movie
dot object
object dot
get
where the uuid
is equal to
movie
underscore id
right
the next thing that we want to do is
that if
the movie exists then you want to return
a render
sorry if i transfer return law
return a render
of requests
and we are going to save it with the
movie
detail dot html pa
template we are going to pass along
a contest dictionary
sorry
i'm going to pass along the movie
the movie that we had
all right
but you want to check for exception
exception the only exception that we
have to check is there
if the movie does not exist okay
so if the movie does not exist
let's clear this exception from there
and use the movie
dot das
does not exist
okay
if it doesn't exist what you what do you
want you do want to return a redirect to
the profile page okay
to the profile list page okay
so return
i redirect
to
a reverse url to profile
underscore list
like this okay
so now we have our view done so let's
add it to our url.py file
okay so instead of uswifi what you are
going to do is you are going to first
import
show
movie
detail
okay
so we are going to use it inside our
path so i'm going to create a new part
here
and our url is going to be class movie
slash
detail
slash
i'm going to take in a dynamic value
which is going to be
power movie
id
okay
and you close it out it's an ending
slash
okay so we are going to use the show
movie
defill
if i can explore my
detail
oh okay
they are going to use the dot as view
on it
and let's give it a name
okay and then it's going to be called
show
and that's called dates so
a short
version of show detail
let's keep the list running
all right let's save it
okay so now we have that working but
where we want to use it actually is
inside their
home
what's the name their home uh where the
movies are listed so that when the user
click on this one like this to take it
to
the
what's the name the
the detail page of this particular movie
okay so let's add it let's add a url to
this one
to the movie list page
so where we are returning this hash
this href hash
we are going to use
we are going to use a url instead of the
hash so
i'm going to return a url here
so we are going to go to call now call
the show
underscore that
they are going to provide their movie id
okay
we underscore id it's going to be go to
movie
dot uu
id all right
so let's save it
all right so
now
let's refresh this thing again
now let's over this so now you can see
it is sending us to the detail over here
so let's click on it and see where it
will send us to
okay so now it sends us to a detail page
but the details there are static data so
we need to
make it dynamic so that it uses
the one for the particular movie that we
just chose okay
so let's go into we can close this one
over the movie dave list
and open up the movie detail template
so
so open up show movie detail
and let me expand my so that you see
everything up okay so an open show movie
detail
hey
the movie detail template the first
thing that i am going to change is the
uh listing over here i'm going to change
it so it uses the movie title
so
because we are sending in a context with
the name movie you can get from it to
the title
all right the next thing that you
you want to change is this thing over
here
i'm going to use
the movie detail
that was provided
you're going to get some weird stuff
about
movie
description
was it was how this part
description okay
and
i just want to make some changes here
let's add this
where is this thing going to
let's adjust this oh
let's add an in
an inline style here so now you can see
the button
just it's not showing for the
meantime let's just add a color
of black to it so that letter become
black
right
where does it move to
hey this is my laptop it's red
oh
let's go it will come back to where it's
supposed to be
let's park again
okay
so we are making it that's the insta
inline style black the color the test
black okay so here we are using dynamic
data
i'm going to just take everything off
we are going to render
our movie description over here to
movie underscore
the description
so this part where it's
on the image or
that is the header part you can
slice the detail
and just take like maybe 50 characters
or 100 characters that's
depending on your preference so that you
don't jump up
the front at the first page this page
this part
so i just show some a little bit of a
summary to it okay then you show all the
details below
inside the real description below okay
the next thing i want to do is the image
the background
okay so this time around you're not
getting this from assist
as
i said that says assets
or from static sorry from static this
area i'm going to use
a media url okay
so
we are going to
grab this one
and it is going to be the flyer
a url so it's going to be movie
dot flyer
that's url okay
so you save it up
then now let's go back
and refresh this thing
okay so you can see the flyer is in
the description
is also in but
something is wrong wrong somewhere i
think i spot something wrong and the
styling too is off so
let's
i think the styling i know where their
error is coming from
so the styling the only thing i need to
do is just take off this
thing
justify end from the session
i want to select you
address for description
movie dot description
movie the description oh no
read the description is it
let me see whether you made the same
mistake over here
um
there's a description over here so
let's save it
go back and try it for the
for one time and see where that's gonna
work
all right so it seems that
there's no description
for the movie and to yet
well i thought there was a description
guys let me check that quickly okay
okay guys so i've actually confirmed
that it seems
darren we're making the spelling for the
model we made a mistake we didn't spoil
the description well i omitted the t
so
you can
correct that make migration
and migrate then you have everything but
i'm just going to
just use it like that just take off the
tee so it's work
so you can just correct that on your end
okay
i'll have to
have to
do one
okay guys so let's refresh
so
so you can see now the description is
now coming through
this is it then we have the other one
too over here
so
i just noticed one thing i tried to log
out over here let's see
and i had this red arrow
it actually didn't log out wow
okay
maybe i don't know why but when i tried
to log out i had a csrf arrow
okay guys so you can see now the
description is coming through
so you can make it better
we have already wasted a lot of time so
i can't
go
about making description and other stuff
so
the styling and everything has been done
for you just have to place in more
detail
more objects inside there
the admin just create more instances
okay but there's one thing i i want to
help you
do that
which is if there is
the movie is a seasonal movie we have to
display you see when it is you're
watching a netflix movie and you go to
the detail page and then it's a seasonal
movie they show you the episodes and you
can choose which episode that you want
to watch
that's what i want us to do
i'm going to copy some code then i'm
going to explain it but i'm not actually
going to
actually going to create a seasonal
movie so that we uh
experiment with it okay
but i'm going to try my best to make it
clear
so i will be able to understand it
so scroll down a little bit outside the
session
okay
so above the description over here
i'm going to paste in some code you can
pause it and
type it in
okay so
let me paste it in
okay so this is it so first i'm checking
the movie type to see whether it is
equal to seasonal so if it is season i'm
going to create a dev here
and i'm going to display an h2
same episodes
and i'm going to loop over
the
the movies inside
the the movies inside all the videos
that has been linked to that movie uh
that movie instance okay so a movie is
linked to a video instance okay so let's
say a particular
a particular episode that has been
linked to its
main
main main movie okay
so i'm going to loop over it
then i'm going to first get today
get what gets the for loop counter which
is provided to us by jungle
and i'm going to get the movie the
episode title okay
so then i display all that
then you can see i am making some href
over here so you let me take
i'm going to leave it for the meantime
i'm making some url over here which is
going to core play we have not yet
created it
then i'm
adding the movie id here then i am
adding what an epi the api is going to
be help us get to the particular episode
that was clicked on so i will be able to
show
the user
the particular episode that they clicked
on and not the first movie okay
so
this is it
so you can just type in this code it
will become more clear if you test it
yourself okay
so
that is it
okay
so
what you are going to do next is you are
going to create the page that is going
to show us the movie itself okay so and
click on the play button
display button over here
you'll be able to
know
which
be able to play the movie to us okay
so let's go back into our views where's
my view
where's my
okay
so i've opened up my view
and
first the before we begin that i want us
to protect this route so let's just copy
this method over here
copy this
then place it on top of this one
so we are just creating it with a login
required
the creator
then let's move down
okay so i'm going to create a new class
that class is also going to be protected
and it's going to be called class
show
movie so it's going to show us the movie
and it's going to inherit from view
and you're going to have a
deficit and that takes sense of
taking request
takes in the movie id
we underscore id
i'm going to take in
axe
action quarks
okay
then
we are going to try and get to the movie
so
i'm going to start a movie instance
and i'm going to get
the movie
dot objects
dot get
no objects
object don't get
i'm going to give it a uu id
and
it's going to be equal to the movie
underscore id
okay
then
you are going to
return
we are going to illustrate
let's re
movie
i'm going to reassign the movie
constant or the movie variable to
movie the value
movie dot
videos
let me move this thing up a little bit
i can see what's going on
with the video
videos dot
value
okay
so we are going to get some sort of a
list
okay
we are going to
return it
return a render
of
requests
we are going to return
the template show
movie
dot html
all right
then
we're going to add a contest
a
is going to have the quantization
this movie
this way sorry
this way okay
the right way
okay so now we are going to
have an exception you are going to check
for movie
dot
does
not exist
if it does not exist
you guys know this what do you want to
do you want to return
a redirect
everyday to
for
a proofer
underscore list
okay so this is it
so we are done with this part
so let's save it
now let's
go and understand
this view to our
our urls
so first let's import it in
then let's create
a path for it so we are going to
give it to a part
i'm going to call that particular part
play
and oh sorry no play
movie
slash play
slash
if i can spell movie well what's all
this
of this last place last
str which is going to be
we underscore id
okay
let's get out of it
then
movie dot ask view show movie dot as you
are going to call it
the name is going to be clay
all right
so
let's save it up
and now
the next thing i want to do is that we
want to use this url inside the show
movie so that's when a user clicks on
the button play inside it it's take them
to this home page
pick them to this page okay or this
route
so let's go into our movie detail page
and what you are going to do is you are
going to wrap around this button
an anchor flag
so
down quarter is going to have
a url
that is going to point to play
oh sorry call dot play call column play
like this
because you are using a namespace
so you're going to have your movie
id
going to be equal to
movie dot uuid
okay
then
let's move in this button this whole
button over here
save it up
now let's go to
uh uh detail page narrator test refresh
hope you don't get any error
okay so now you have an error so this
thing now can take us to our play page
let's click on it
okay so we have an error
that's beautiful
okay said doesn't have value
probably it's true it doesn't have value
no probably it doesn't have value it's
supposed to be values
so let's change this thing over here
now let's refresh this thing
okay now it says
okay so
it's supposed to be slash
so let's go into our show
movie
instead of it's being
movie dots
now
dot number by supposed to be persia
slash
this way
save it
now let's
refresh again
okay so now you can see
we have our page
showing but the movie is now it's not
it's not being played okay
that's sad no netflix netflix without a
movie
that's bad so let's go into our
our template once again
so this is where we are going to make
the magic happen so that
so instead of showing this
static
uh movie that is rendering from some
asset then
which is not working so
clearly let's take it off
let's take this whole thing off
all right
so we are going to using some javascript
okay
so first thing you are going to do is
you are going to
pass
the
the value that is going to be sent from
the front end is going to be in a form
of a that is going to be sent from the
back end
or the view is going to be in the form
of a list so we want to pass it
then send it to
so our javascript be able to have access
to it okay so the best way to do it is
to use the json
the script json scripts uh tag okay
so
the name of it is going to be movie
now he's in
there json scripts
okay so jsonscript
we are going to give it
a name
i'm going to call it movie
and that's called data
okay
so beneath this main i'm going to paste
in some javascript that i'm going to go
through and explain it for you guys okay
so
okay so this is the javascript
over here so this is it
this is basically it's let me i want to
get everything
what's up
let me
control
c or z or z
instead okay so there's everything on
right now so
first i am getting um
selecting this video tag here
then i am passing
this data that has that i've sent from
the
from the view here which is in the form
of a list
let me i'm grabbing it over here
this is how you do it okay
so when i'm done
i'm creating a new url with the
location.ref which is the current url
that we are on
then i try to get out a parameter
the parameter is called the epi so when
you check the movie detail when
i added this
let me show it to you so it becomes a
little bit clear
when i added this
block of code
that was looping over the movie so in
case it sees now movie it's going to
have an epi at the end which is going to
tell us which particular episode the
user wants to watch
okay
so
that's what the epi is for it's like for
episode okay
so
that's what i'm trying to grab from the
url
okay
so
i'm trying to grab that from the url
but if it does not has an api then it
means that the person is trying to watch
a single movie so we make that
video parameter one at zero so if it has
the api then it sets it to the api okay
and it is passing into an integer so
whatever that is going to come out is
going to be an integer okay
then
we try to select the video further we
want to watch so
the listener that is going to come out
of here is going to provide is going to
give us a list of video files okay
so
the video file is going to be in order
so episode if it's a seasonal movie
episode one is going to be first episode
two is going to be second three and in
that order okay so we get to that
particular
episode then we get to the file the file
is going to give us a url
okay
the file is going to give us a url
then we just match that
part to
this thing over here
this
this our root url which is pointing to
our media files okay i hope i didn't
confuse anyone okay
so this is how you are doing it so let's
save it
and let's go back and refresh
okay so it seems you have some error
somewhere
okay so it says you can't pass what
about about json so i think i know where
the error is coming from
so
so instead of
inside the view.py file here
instead of sending the movie
you're going to send a list
i'm going to wrap it around a list okay
so
and make it a list instead of a query
query whatever that i'm talking about
so let's save it
that way to be able to pass it to json
so now let's refresh
okay
so now you can see this time around we
have a video showing up
so you can play the video
at some reach
yet very simple short video that i
downloaded from somewhere okay
so
so you can see everything is working now
we can play a video so let's let's go
back
you can go back
okay so
when you go back then you click this
thing over here play
going to send us to
the page where the movie is supposed to
play then voila we can
go ahead and play our movie okay so guys
this is basically the end of our the
the tutorial